hey matt it's time to react to tick
tocks
you know if i were to come up with a
ranking of species um i think of course
i'd put humans at the top and then maybe
chimpanzees elephants dogs actually dogs
would be even farther down and then you
get uh you get to like squirrels and
rats and bugs and then beneath that you
would finally get to male feminists i
don't like male females in other words
what i'm trying to say we've watched
some male feminist tick-tock videos
before and i was just thinking that i'm
not depressed enough today or angry
enough so we're going to dive in once
again and see what the male feminists of
tik-tok have to offer us so let's check
this out when i asked men what they
feared as much as a woman feared being
raped i had three answers show up a
number of times two of them i think we
can dismiss and one of them seemed valid
the first one was that men said they
feared not measuring up but while that's
a valid fear the pressure you put on
yourself to live up to your perceived
role in society is very different than
the fear a woman may have of what a man
may do to her without her consent vastly
different fears let's put that one aside
the second one i saw a lot of was men
saying that they feared being falsely
accused of rape and having that ruin
their lives first of all demonstratively
untrue trump kavanaugh secondly while
rape statistics are notoriously hard to
pin down it's at least arguable that a
man is more likely to be raped than to
be falsely accused of rape the threat is
vanishingly small so what checks all the
boxes what has the systemic pervasive of
the antagonism the the realistic threats
of violence
the one that rang true to me
was how black men fear the police
wow so insightful okay first of all um
well
i i love how he wants to give examples
he wants he wants to ex
explain
why false accusations of rape wants to
prove why that's not a real threat and
then he lists two guys who were falsely
accused that would be trump and
kavanaugh but before we even get to that
what the hell kind of bizarre question
is this how can i rank my degree of fear
in a particular thing against someone
else's degree of fear in something else
how do i even do and why
so now we're competing to see who has
the most fear oh i'm more fearful than
you see i win
the appropriate response to that
question is what
what the hell are you talking about
why are you asking me that you weirdo
who you talking to i also don't believe
that any man was actually asked what do
you fear as much as women fear being
raped and answered i fear not measuring
up
but if i were to actually you know
engage the question
here's something that men could fear i
don't know being murdered
because men are much more likely to be
murdered than women
[Applause]
[Music]
men are more likely to die in car
accidents too so you could you could
fear car accidents
[Applause]
men are more likely to end up homeless
or in prison
[Applause]
of all these fears the police are the
least rational thing to fear especially
for black men as more unarmed white men
are shot by cops each year than on our
black men
but for both races the incidents are so
vanishingly rare that it's not worth
thinking about that boy is good
all right let's continue welcome to
content 101 where i teach grown ass men
what consent is
a lot of you seem to think of consent as
an unbreakable trade agreement
this is normal when patriarchy cuddles
your entire life to the point you feel
entitled to someone else's body
you think that your is more important
than a human person
what may be shocking to you is that it
is not you're not entitled someone
else's body your is not more important
than a human person and consent is not
an unbreakable trade agreement
once consent is given it can be taken
away anytime that the person who gave
the consent wishes therefore if a person
says yes 10 times but no on the 11th
time then if you continue it is rape
likewise if a person says no ten times
but at the end gives in and says yes
just to shut you up it is at the very
least sexual harassment and manipulation
and worst case scenario is still rape
if you need more elaboration i would be
happy to give you some in the meanwhile
don't be a rapist
um here we have of course the male
feminist favorite pastime he enjoys
nothing so much as talking about how
opposed he is to rape so there's
definitely a he doth protest too much
sort of situation happening here
hey guys listen controversial statement
here but i'm just going to come out and
say it
rape is bad
that's like every male feminist
tick-tock video bold stuff chief
no one needs the videos explaining well
this is rape rape is bad here's why rape
is bad that's that's one of the main
problems with these anti-rape explainers
is that they seem to imply that rape is
the result of misunderstandings
every single person on earth
knows that rape is bad knows what rape
is and knows how not to rape people
everyone knows that and then you'll say
well what do you mean there are are you
saying that there are no rapists in the
world no of course they're rapists they
know that it's wrong and they're doing
it anyway rape murder awesome and rape
you said rape twice i like rape what do
you think that there are rapists out
there that are going around raping women
and they're going to see this male
feminist tick tock video don't be a
rapist oh so oh so we're not supposed to
do that you're saying oh well that's
silly me
he also says if a woman says no 10 times
and then says yes
it's still no
so we shouldn't take a woman at her word
a woman a woman can change her mind and
decide that she doesn't want to have sex
you're saying i agree there but she
can't change her mind to decide that she
does want to have sex or sometimes she
can but sometimes she can and it's up to
you
to decide which is which
a few decades ago private citizens used
to be largely that private what's
changed well the internet think about
everything you browse searched for
watched or tweeted now imagine all of
that data being crawled through
collected and aggregated by third
parties into a permanent public record
your record having your private life
exposed for others to see was once
something only celebrities worried about
but an era where everybody is online
everyone is a public figure we're all
kind of celebrities in our own right to
keep my data private then i go online i
turn to expressvpn
every time i turn the expressvpn on i'm
given a random ip address shared by
other expressvpn customers that makes it
more difficult for third parties to
identify me and harvest my data
the best part is how easy expressvpn is
to use no matter what device you're on
whether it's a phone laptop smart tv
whatever it is all you have to do is tap
one button to get protected it really is
that simple so if like me you believe
that your data is your business secure
yourself with the number one rated vpn
on the market visit
expressvpn.comwall should get three
extra months for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s
vpn.com walsh go to expressvpn.comwalsh
to learn more
men fear that women will laugh at them
women fear that men will kill them and
this is why men especially straight
cisgendered white men are so incredibly
fragile historically speaking in
patriarchal systems when women piss off
men they are putting themselves in
life-threatening danger which leads to
women having to tone police themselves
as a defense mechanism consciously or
otherwise women go out of their way to
either withhold criticism from men or to
deliver it as gently as possible which
results in an entire society of men that
don't even realize that they expect to
be coddled by the women in their lives
and so when rightly receiving criticism
or anger from women men tend to react
like toddlers so gentlemen
shut up
toughen up and listen to and acknowledge
the reality of the lived experience of
women because it shouldn't take a
straight passing cisgendered white man
telling you this for you to listen
straight passing
buddy you're about as straight passing
as a circle okay
you pass for straight about as much as i
pass for a
19 year old black lesbian
that's that's all i'm gonna say about
that let's just keep going
[Music]
okay so that was that was brave that was
another brave and bold one me too i am
also opposed to that bad thing
i i also don't like bad things ladies
someone give me a cookie
by the way is is sexualization is is
that a bad thing or not now because i'm
confused isn't it empowering for a woman
to use her sexuality in that way or is
it only empowering when she does it on
only fans or pornhub
[Music]
i mean the woman who had her legs spread
for the hamburger advertisement or
whatever it was
she wasn't there against her will
the the hamburger people didn't have a
gun to her head
she chose to do that and isn't that
empowering for her to make that choice
for herself and what i know for sure is
that if this had been a video defending
sexualized advertisements as advert as
as empowering for women that same doofus
on the right would have still been there
with his hand raised saying i agree
because it doesn't matter what's being
said he's still going to have his hand
raised saying he agrees tell me about
the time when you realize that the bar
is super low for men i've known this for
a while but a good example of this
happened a couple days ago i was with
one of my best female friends i won't
tell you her name because privacy but
she told me that when she first met me i
made her super uncomfortable in a
predatory a salty sort of way well i
immediately started freaking out i was
like yo tell me what i did so that i
could never do that to anyone ever again
and she said no no no no it's nothing
you did you you have nothing to
apologize for
and then she would go on to tell me that
the fact i treated her with decency
respect and like a person was
off-putting because she thought oh he
just wants to get in my pants she told
me that she only let her guard down
around me when she found out i was
dating someone else at the time
the fact that this guy is trying to
manipulate me into sex seemed more
likely than this guy is a good person is
sad
lots of things are sad about that i i
mean you know but you know what i i take
it all back everything i said about male
feminist they're not a bunch of
ridiculous weasels it turns out they're
heroes i mean this guy recorded a whole
video to tell us about the time that he
was so nice and gentlemanly and
respectful of of a woman that she
assumed he was a rapist
i'm such a nice guy that women think i'm
going to rape them is what he's saying
because that makes a lot of sense
doesn't it by the way if the story is
even true which probably isn't
isn't this a story about a cynical
self-obsessed woman who assumes that
everyone around her is trying to sleep
with her
is his friend aoc by the way
yeah
yeah you thought you were going to be
right yeah
all right we'll try i can only adore one
more so let's uh
continue
men fear no not this guy yet shut up
women all right because let's be honest
feminism has left men behind
no
that is factually inaccurate the very
things you describe in your video as
feminism for men
are things that feminism have enabled
men to do
only feminism has allowed men to create
the spaces where they can behave as they
want to without fear of retribution
we
benefit from feminism every day
we benefit from feminism more than women
do
i'm i'm not even sure what he was trying
to say there
um
i honestly don't know but in fairness
that video probably didn't really belong
in this compilation anyway because we're
talking about male feminists which would
seem to exclude anybody with purple hair
so that probably we shouldn't put that
video there at all
and uh i was gonna keep going but i
honestly can't i'm i'm nauseated so
that's it
don't be a rapist